[Applause]
they are the nightmare images Nicholas
sturgeon would rather forget detectives
swarming her house days after she quit
as first Minister officers examining SMP
finances bagging evidence in April the
same day her husband Peter motto was
arrested
I understand
nothing could be further from the truth
but now she was the suspect detained and
facing questions in custody for seven
hours Nicholas sturgeon is staying away
from her property here but she did
release a statement after being released
without charge and she said the whole
thing has been deeply distressing and
she is innocent of wrongdoing she also
stressed that she would never harm the
SNP but the reality is the last few
months have been the most difficult the
party has ever faced I've covered
Scottish politics since Braveheart was a
boy and I have never seen anything quite
as uh as as dramatic and chaotic as this
this is particularly challenging for for
Hamza Yusuf he is facing difficulties
already as I say with with government
problems he's facing difficulties with
um individual discontent and disquiet
within his party this has been a
long-running police probe stretching
back to March 2021 when a complaint was
launched about 6 hundred thousand pounds
raised to support a second Independence
referendum by July detectives launch
Operation Branch form amid seven reports
fast forward to February this year
Nicholas sturgeon resigned around a
month later Hamza Yusuf was crowned SMP
leader then came the arrest of recently
departed chief executive Peter Morrell
and eventually the SMP Treasurer Colin
bitty was also detained
crisis weighing heavy on Hamza Yusuf a
close Ally of Nicholas sturgeon the pair
in regular talks in recent days I've
been asking about her welfare uh she has
mentioned her difficult and traumatic
those last few weeks have been is she
okay yeah she's in a good place in doing
well for sure but also yes of course so
why would I not want to get some advice
from I think arguably one of the best
politicians and most impressive
politicians Europe has seen over the
last couple of decades but that was then
and this is now Nicholas sturgeon
insists she will carry on as a
politician but there is no doubt her
arrest creates a fresh headache for the
party she once LED Conor Gillis Sky News
Glasgow